but we are going to begin with the
earthquakes in turkey and Devastation on
a scale that is difficult to imagine
workers are digging through the rubble
now for a fourth day across a widespread
area of Destruction the death toll has
climbed to more than 17
000 people and this morning we've
learned at least three Americans are
among those killed Chris livesay is in
southern turkey for us the numbers are
one thing but Chris what are you seeing
good morning Dana Rescuers are furiously
hacking away at the residential building
behind me to see if there are any
survivors and there may be one we were
just told that a teenage girl managed to
send a text message to a friend telling
her she was still alive now this was
just after the earthquake and so far
there's no sign of her but that's why
these Rescuers are just furiously
removing every piece of rubble they can
just like they are in so many other
places across this earthquake-stricken
territory
it's been three days the earthquake
killed Abdullahi moana's wife and buried
him alive
in 72 hours fending off exposure
hypothermia and unimaginable grief the
unseasonable cold as much as 15 degrees
lower than normal has made the
catastrophe even more lethal says the
World Health Organization we've got a
lot of people who have survived now out
in the open in immersioning and horrific
conditions we've got major disruption to
fuel and electricity plays communication
supplies the basics of life
we are in real danger we're seeing a
secondary disaster which may
um cause harm to more people than the
initial disaster International relief is
pouring in including two search and
rescue teams from the U.S ambassador
Jeff Flake tells us we also have a
couple of Blackhawks to see the assets
they have the Machinery you know to cut
through concrete and rebar and the dogs
as well to try to find those survivors
still there so it's just
when we respond we do it well
help that cannot come quickly enough
my mother father and brother are under
the rubble Selena come in cries there's
been no sound from them for days none
it's not just time that they're working
against but it's the cold it's been a
severe Factor throughout this entire
earthquake response the volunteers here
themselves are also victims in many
cases they've lost their homes and now
they're digging with buckets they're
bare hands whatever they have on No
Sleep Tony
voices in the rubble fall silent Chris
livesight in Turkey thank you very much